she's had conflicts with an iconic star
she loves the role she's lesser known
for she was casting spells while
fighting breast cancer there's a lot you
may not know about the lovely maggie
smith keep watching to learn more about
this beloved dame today's audience might
see maggie smith's work on the harry
potter movies as the high point of her
career however the actress has worked
with the biggest industry stalwarts of
several generations her flying start
began with an early partnership with
cinema legend lawrence olivier it
wouldn't be too much to call olivier the
equivalent of tom cruise leonardo
dicaprio and johnny depp for his time he
has a whopping 85 acting credits to his
name that spanned from the 1930s all the
way to the late 80s he also had a keen
eye for talent according to michael
covney's book maggie smith a biography
olivier was so entranced by smith's
performance in the play the double
dealer that he personally invited her to
join his theater company in major roles
unfortunately smith's strong personality
frequently clashed with oliviers as
company told the mirror the pair soon
became quote professional rivals larry
used to say there was a merry war
between us the conflict led to an
altercation in the middle of a
problematic performance of the 1965 play
othello in a later scene in the play
olivier playing a fellow was supposed to
slap smith according to accounts by
company and smith olivier actually hit
smith knocking her out
when it comes to acting awards for
actresses several famous names and
characters tend to come to mind
considering maggie smith's career which
began in the 1950s there are hardly any
noteworthy acting awards she's yet to
achieve a complete list of awards won by
smith would be longer than this video
itself however some of the major
highlights include two oscars for her
roles in the prime of miss jean brodie
and california suite she's also received
five baftas four emmys and a tony award
for lettuce and lovage smith's honors
even transcend traditional acting awards
most famously the actress was made a
dame commander of the order of the
british empire in 1990 according to
vogue smith was also named a companion
of honor in 2014
maggie smith's love life has had nearly
as much drama as her storied career in
1967 smith married celebrated actor
robert stevens unfortunately their
marriage was not a happy one and the two
got divorced through a mutual agreement
in 1975 smith remarried playwright
beverly cross the pair had fallen in
love years earlier but cross was already
married at the time when they finally
came together the pair enjoyed more than
two decades of wedded bliss until
cross's untimely passing the actress
still feels the loss of her second
husband keenly as she admitted to the
telegraph it seems a bit pointless going
on one's own and not having someone to
share a life with despite the turbulence
of her marriage to stevens smith did
have two children with her first husband
both their sons followed their parents
footsteps and entered the entertainment
industry chris larkin born christopher
stevens decided to change his surname
before entering the industry out of a
desire to make it without getting work
based on his parents fame evidently this
approach paid off as he's been working
steadily in films and movies since 1995
meanwhile his brother toby stevens has
been working in a range of production
since 1992 he has appeared in movies
british television stage plays and even
a bollywood film
while maggie smith has long been
hollywood's go-to actress whenever you
need someone who can shrivel up their
co-stars with a single sharp gaze fellow
actress judy dench can always command a
room as well not only is dench a fellow
dame but she and smith have been close
friends for several decades the duo met
and became firm friends when they were
both up and coming members of london's
old vic theater apparently despite being
known as the soul of professionalism
smith told ew the pair of veteran
actresses laughed so much when they're
together they struggled not to break on
camera the idea of the two dames being
friends has tickled the fancy of the
public so much that their relationship
inspired a documentary 2018's tea with
the dames features smith and dench
together with their fellow dames and
veteran actresses eileen atkins and joan
plowright while very little actual tea
features in the special the name of the
beverage refers to the golden nuggets of
gossip that the dames occasionally
divulged during the course of their
conversation
generally accepted to be one of the most
talented actresses in the world maggie
smith's arresting eyes make up an
integral part of her commanding
on-screen presence the actress's
well-known protuberant gaze can make
anyone on the receiving end feel
automatically inferior and even guilty
for no reason that was part of what made
smith such an effective professor
mcgonagall it turns out the actress's
slightly bulging eyes are a result of
her battles with an immune system
disorder called graves disease the
disorder results in an overproduction of
thyroid hormones that can have a variety
of physical manifestations according to
an interview with the new york times
smith was diagnosed with a condition in
1988 at the age of 54. one of the
symptoms smith suffered from was the
protrusion of the eyes also known as
graves ophthalmopathy which left her
eyes painfully sore smith told the times
magazine that she went through quote 12
months of near isolation which included
radiotherapy and eye surgery to keep the
symptoms under control
while the harry potter movies are
generally renowned for hitting the nail
on the head with casting most of the
characters from jk rowling's iconic book
series maggie smith's portrayal of
minerva mcgonagall is considered
particularly fitting with her witch's
robes spectacles and perpetually strict
expression smith's mcgonagall looks to
have stepped straight out of the books
whenever she appears on screen opposite
daniel radcliffe's harry potter for
radcliffe and smith their bond was
established a year before a single frame
of the first harry potter movie was ever
shot in 1999 the two actors starred
together in a two-part bbc television
drama adaptation of charles dickens
iconic 1850 novel david copperfield
radcliffe played the younger version of
the titular character while smith
assumed the role of betsy trotwood while
the world of david copperfield is far
removed from harry potter the two had an
important correlation for radcliffe in
an interview on the late show with
stephen colbert radcliffe explained that
smith played a big part in getting him
the titular role in harry potter but
maggie
was the person that like recommended me
for potter and so she's the reason i
ended up doing that with the harry
potter films mainly centered around
harry and his friends smith's main
responsibility in the film was to look
strict and occasionally take points off
gryffindor it turns out smith was not
the only actor on set who was chafing
about the one note nature of their role
a fellow sufferer was alan rickman who
played the controversial character
severus snape like smith rickman was
usually only required to stand in the
back and react with a scowl at whatever
harry happened to be doing at the moment
the job got so monotonous that smith and
rickman used to have a hard time trying
to squeeze out different reactions for
the same shot smith told npr that when
the kids shots were filmed she and her
peers would need to film dozens of
different reactions which could get
quite arduous after a while
for the rest of the world actors like
maggie smith and ian mckellen are
serious thespians who only exist to
produce one remarkable performance after
another like their virtuosic
predecessors one day these legends will
retire having left an irreparable mark
on the industry the truth is veteran
actors are regular people who have known
each other for decades as they cross
paths through their work it's no
surprise that such old friends are not
above pulling each other's legs when ian
mckellen was hosting saturday night live
one of the bits that proved the most
popular was when mckellen dressed up as
maggie smith during a weekend update
session alongside jimmy fallon
the best supporting actress who's that
not me whether i win it or not okay i
understood
smith's reaction to the bit was just as
mcgonagall as you can expect during an
interview with the evening standard the
actress remarks that she was afraid of
going to see mckellen's one-man show
because she feared he'd do an impression
of her she went on to add he does them
all the time i rather acidly told him
that i'd done one of him but people
didn't know him well enough to recognize
it unfortunately smith's hopes of
avoiding mckellen's impression of
herself were dashed when he busted
another one out during an interview with
graham norton
graves disease was not the only serious
illness that maggie smith had to contend
with in her life in the late 2000s the
actress was diagnosed with breast cancer
ever the inspiration smith continued to
work even while she was receiving
chemotherapy to deal with the illness in
fact she filmed mcgonagall's scenes for
harry potter and the deathly hallows in
the middle of her treatment the wig she
wore helped disguise the fact that her
natural hair had fallen out due to the
effects of the chemotherapy smith has
also stated that she had to hold on to
the railings next to her in her scenes
because she was too weak to stand
unsupported despite her weakened health
smith fought hard and finished filming
the last potter movie in doing so she
got to film her character's most
triumphant scene her epic battle with
severus snape in the great hall
thankfully smith's treatment worked and
she was able to return to her regular
life
for the current generation of audiences
maggie smith will forever be known as
professor mcgonagall from harry potter
or violet crowley from downton abbey
smith was perfectly cast in both roles
and the countless fans who delighted to
see her play those parts over so many
years might be saddened to hear the
actress herself is not particularly fond
of either of them never one to mince her
words smith made her feelings clear
during an interview for the evening
standard she explained that while she's
incredibly thankful for the opportunity
to perform in both harry potter and
downton abbey the work itself wasn't
particularly gratifying she told es it
wasn't what you'd call satisfying i
didn't really feel i was acting in those
things while fans might disagree with
her smith has played a great range of
leading and supporting roles over a
storied career filled with complex and
fascinating characters that an actor can
really sink their teeth into compared to
those mcgonagall and crawley can seem a
bit one note still smith mentions that
the one thing she particularly enjoyed
about doing the harry potter movies was
how thrilled her grandchildren were by
the fact that she was a part of that
magical world
these days maggie smith is long past the
age when most professionals begin
contemplating retirement but despite
having already achieved everything an
actor could possibly achieve in the
field smith shows no signs of slowing
down in fact the actress intends to keep
working as long as the roles keep coming
unfortunately for smith her rampant
success has made aspects of her private
life fairly difficult she does not seem
to like divulging personal information
to the public eye and she told the
telegraph she can no longer travel alone
without being mobbed by fans despite the
long hours and the endless gaze of the
public smith told the sunday times she
would miss the atmosphere on set too
much if she ever chose to retire from
acting she explained when you're not
working it's scary and when you are
working it's scary because you don't
know if you've got the energy to get
through the day the bleakness of not
doing it and missing out on the
friendships that you make is too much to
bear fortunately age has proved no
obstacle to smith lighting up the screen
with her presence and if fans are lucky
they can expect to see many more
outstanding performances in the coming
years
what an invigorating prospect check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about maggie
smith are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]